There's a movement afoot in this country.
A student-led revolution.
A rallying cry for change in an otherwise unchanged educational system.
People like me have something to say.
People like me demand to be heard.
People like me think it's time higher education was held to a higher standard.
Because it's time all people with talent were recognized.
It's time technology transformed the way universities teach...
...and tradition no longer stood in the way of getting an education.
People like me want a choice.
People like me want to make a difference.
People like me demand a different kind of university.
One that puts my talent first.
One that learns how I learn.
To challenge me.
To support me.
Online, on campus.
On my terms.
It's time a university recognized people like me.
People like me.